the cold war is often seen as two united
sides facing off in an ideological
battle for the future
yet as many of you will have guessed
this wasn't always the case and both
sides had their own more rebellious
members
in the case of the west this was france
and their withdrawal from nato in 1966
at the height of the cold war is often
discussed as an example of this
this course of action seems like it
wouldn't have been a good idea at this
point and thus raises the question
why why did france withdraw from nato so
just to make it clear despite what's
often discussed france didn't actually
withdraw from nato entirely but from its
unified command structure
it was still fully committed to
defending other nato members in the case
of war and the command structure it had
just left was created to lead and
coordinate nato's many militaries in the
event of such a war
at its head was the supreme allied
commander who could be from any of
nato's member states so long as that
member state began with eu and ended
with united states of america
second in command was the deputy allied
commander who could also be from any
nato country but in reality
just britain this upset french president
charles de gaulle who felt that it would
be nice if a frenchman could gain the
position at least once
and so in 1966 he withdrew french forces
from nato's unified command structure
this wasn't just done for the sake of
pride but because de gaulle wanted to
ensure french strategic independence
he and many in the military were
concerned that france would become
reliant on nato for operational planning
and thus would no longer be self-reliant
for france's budding nuclear arsenal
this meant zero collaboration in terms
of joint nuclear strategy with britain
and america
and in terms of conventional forces
france's leadership wanted the french
army to be totally independent in terms
of tactics procurement and policy
there were also concerns about placing
french troops under the command of
non-french leaders and how they would be
used this concern wasn't exactly new
either and was the reason that the
french had withdrawn their navy from the
unified command structure in the
previous decade
this all culminated in a small
diplomatic row with the usa
when leaving nato's command structure to
gaul also ordered all foreign troops out
of france
president johnson saw this coming and
when to goul made the former request for
all american troops to depart france his
government's response was does that
include those in the cemeteries as well
furthermore france also banned the
housing of american nuclear weapons on
its soil
importantly these changes were
incredibly popular with the french
people which is why no french leaders
changed their arrangement for the rest
of the century
now this move wasn't france's first move
towards leaving nato altogether
in fact de gaulle had signed a secret
agreement with the united states
promising that france would rejoin the
unified command structure in the event
of a soviet invasion
and whilst many nato members were
completely outraged at the french move
the american response was one of
resigned disagreement in their eyes nato
did not need france in it to survive and
the johnson administration was convinced
that it would only be five or ten years
until france rejoined although they'd
have to wait slightly longer than that
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker rob
waterhouse moe
marvin cassell aaron the white jordan
longley james castaneda gustav swan
jerry lamden
maggie patzkowski copper tone rasheed
ali winston k
wood misses it spinning three plates
lexi schwinn matthew shipley anthony
beckett robert wetzel
marcus arsenault corso wolf spencer
lightfoot and charles the first